hey this is presh tollwacker
we have the following word problem with
the following diagram that is not to
scale
triangle ABC has a b equal to 10 BC
equal to 10 AC equal to 10 root 2. the
triangle is folded so that point a falls
on the midpoint M of BC
the crease endpoints p q are alongsides
a b and AC respectively what is the
length of the crease PQ
I think Ashish for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
triangle ABC has a b equal to 10 BC
equal to 10 and AC equal to 10 root 2.
we first observe that a b squared plus
BC squared is equal to AC Squared and
that means ABC is a right triangle with
hypotenuse AC
so we will sketch a right triangle ABC
with hypotenuse AC
the triangle is folded so that point a
falls on the midpoint M of BC
so we will imagine making a crease here
so that this triangle gets folded over
the crease
and it results so that a ends up at
Point M which is the midpoint of BC so
that upper triangle gets folded down
over the crease
the crease has endpoints p and Q
alongsides a b and AC so the crease will
be p and Q
we now need to figure out the length of
the crease PQ
so how do we do that there are many ways
to solve this problem in this video I
will illustrate a solution with
coordinate geometry there are many many
reasons to use coordinate geometry one
reason is that it's vital for making
computer Graphics or animation it's
definitely a skill you want to learn
number two coordinate geometry connects
geometry and algebra so you can use the
problem-solving techniques of algebra to
figure out Geometry problems three it's
useful in advanced mathematics many
times you need a coordinate system so
that it will help you understand the
structure of a shape finally it's a
powerful problem solving technique
you just put in coordinates and you can
kind of plug and chug and just hack your
way into the answer that's what I'm
going to illustrate in this question
so we'll start out with a coordinate
system where B is at 0 0.
since a b is equal to 10 point a is at 0
comma ten since BC is equal to 10 C is
going to be at 10 comma 0. now m is the
midpoint of BC so it's at 5 comma zero
now since we have folded a along the
crease PQ resulting in the midpoint M we
must have that AP is equal to pm
this is exactly AP being folded over PQ
we don't know the coordinates of P but
we know that its x coordinate is equal
to zero so let's just say p has
coordinates of zero comma p
we can now use algebra to figure out the
value of P
now the length of AP is equal to 10
minus p
the length of PM we can figure out using
the distance formula
we take the square root of the square of
the difference in x coordinates plus the
square of the difference of the Y
coordinates so we have the square root
of the square of 0 minus 5 plus the
square of P minus 0.
we just simplify this now we can square
both sides
then we can square the binomial on the
left we cancel out the p-squared terms
we put the constant terms on one side
and the p on the other side so we have
20p is equal to 75 and that gives us p
is equal to 15 over 4. and almost like
magic we figure out the coordinates of
Point p
now all we need to do is figure out the
coordinates of Point Q
this will be a little bit trickier
now since we folded about the crease PQ
we know that AQ is equal to qm
but we don't know the coordinates of Q
but we do know that Q is along the line
aqc
so let's figure out the equation for the
line aqc
we'll use the slope intercept formula Y
is equal to m x plus b where m is the
slope and B is the y-intercept
now we already know the y-intercept is
equal to 10 so B is equal to 10.
we know that c is at 10 comma zero so we
could figure out the slope between these
two points
so it'll be the change in Y coordinates
divided by the change in x coordinates
so we have 0 minus 10 divided by 10
minus 0 that will be equal to negative
1.
so we have the equation Y is equal to
Negative X Plus 10. so suppose that
point Q has an x coordinate equal to Q
then the y coordinate will be equal to
negative Q Plus 10.
so now All That Remains is to solve for
Q
we can do that because we know that AQ
is equal to qm in length
now rather than working with square
roots on both sides we can work with the
square distances so we have the square
of the length of AQ is equal to the
square of the length of qm
so we substitute these into the distance
formula and squaring both sides
now we just carefully simplify
we can eliminate terms and we get that Q
is equal to 25 over 6. that's the x
coordinate the y coordinate will be
negative Q Plus 10 so that equals 35
over 6.
so we figured out the coordinates of
Point Q
we need to know the length of the crease
PQ so we just want to figure out the
length of PQ
but we know the coordinates of P are 0
comma 15 over 4 and we know the
coordinates of Q are 25 over 6 and 35
over 6. so we just applied the distance
formula it'll be the square root of the
square of 25 over 6 plus the square of
35 over 6 minus 15 over 4.
I will spare all the details right here
of squaring finding a common denominator
and then finding all of the
simplifications we end up with the
result of 25 root 5 divided by 12 and
that's approximately equal to 4.658
and almost like magic we figured out the
answer with coordinate geometry
wow
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]